anyone who saw those pictures overnight
couldn't help but be moved and as a
father I feel deeply moved by the sight
of that young boy are on a beach in
Turkey and Britain is a moral nation and
we will fulfill our moral
responsibilities that's why i sent the
royal navy to the mediterranean that
saved thousands of lives that's why
britain meets our commitment of naught
point seven percent of our economy spent
on aid much of which goes to north
africa goes to the Middle East to help
those countries that is why Britain's
the second biggest bilateral donor in
the world to those Syrian refugee camp
nobody would like to stay in Hungary so
we don't have difficulties with those
who would like to stay in Hungary nobody
would like to stay in Hungary neither in
Slovakia North Pole and nor Estonia all
of them would like to go to Germany our
job is only to register them Australia
had that economic refugee challenge
before we came to government tens of
thousands of refugees came attempting
refugees came on boats we stop the boats
we lost 1,200 people including children
at sea and when we were elected in the
government we said you have to stop the
boats you have to close down the
business model of the people smugglers
and we do
we have to make sure in Europe that we
coordinate all our efforts in terms of
defense in terms of rescuing people in
terms of receiving those people and I
think we should make sure in Europe that
when we receive these hundreds of
thousands of refugees which are I want
to underline it out political and asylum
refugees they are not economic refugees
so they come for a long time so make
sure that they're going to be integrated
in our societies and also in our
economies